here is the crappy trivia question for
you to answer you cannot make a power
play you must answer who was the last
offensive player to be taken first
overall
that wasn't a quarterback or a tackle
ooh
first last offensive player that was not
oh my gosh man I'm gonna say Keyshawn
Johnson it's rigged somebody cheated
somebody cheated
there's no how did you get there I'm not
good I've told you before I'm a
historian okay I am a historian all
right and I know what the hell I'm
talking about here so okay here we go
you ready first pick first pick I think
I'm gonna have to go with Jim Plunkett
is my first pick okay Jim Plunkett
should have made a power play won the
Heisman came out of Stanford number one
pick all right
gets drafted by then the crappy New
England Patriots kind of an upstart
franchise that's just you know trying to
find their way Jim Plunkett gets stuck
there we don't really know how good he
is oh it's a crap career oh he's a bust
he's a bus oh he goes to the Oakland
Raiders hey they're kind of good guess
what Jim Plunkett kind of looks good
wins two Super Bowls that way that's one
guy that jumps out to me right away
first off in a lot of different ways
never gets in the Hall of Fame
conversation but certainly a guy that
gets stuck in a bad position and we
didn't know how good or talented he was
until he got on a team that could help
show his talents that way so Jim
Plunkett is one that jumps out to me
yeah I like that one I like it but I
don't love it you missed the obvious
number one overall pick it's a guy who
has been an integral part of this Joe
burrows story a guy who was the first
overall pick of the Cincinnati Bank I
didn't think you would go here yeah damn
it I thought you would be snarky and
come up with something cuter than this I
was hoping to save it for round two
first pick
I say I saved the snarky stuff for later
Carson Palmer who ultimately did make a
power play and based upon his comments
about what he learned in Cincinnati
surely wishes he had made a power play
and forced his way to a better
organization in 2003 and when he did
quit on the Bengals and
2011 it was that broken collarbone
suffered by Jason Campbell two days
before the trade deadline that opened
the door for the Bengals to trade Carson
Palmer to the Raiders already gave up
way too much to get Carson Palmer but
they were desperate at that point and
that got him out of Cincinnati he would
later end up in Arizona which really
showed him the contrast between good
organization bad organization
so yes Carson Palmer should have made
the power play back in 2003 when he was
the first overall pick yeah that was
that's that would have been my next pick
I didn't think I thought you would try
to go with something cuter in round one
and I just didn't think you would go
there the obvious route so that kind of
pisses me off cuz I was trying to plan
that out and it didn't work out all
right I'm gonna go with a guy that's
playing right now I'm going with Matthew
Stafford okay Matthew Stafford hey you
know I know you know that I defend him
right I do I think he's been one of the
better quarterbacks of this last liddie
you know 10 12 years he's a lot better
than what people give him credit for is
what I want to say and you know this is
an extremely talented guy who's really
been the only thing positive about the
Detroit Lions for years and years and
years and when they drafted him hey they
were a dumpster fire there's no doubt
about that and you know again here he's
still fighting the stigma of you know
should he be other dude they don't go to
the playoffs and they don't win playoff
games and all that I get it I understand
that does Matthew Stafford have a few
moments in his career that he'd like
back sure but damn he's delivered a lot
more moments with that team and let
allowed coaches to keep jobs and keep
them relevant because of his greatness
he's a victim of his own greatness to a
degree and I just don't think we'll ever
get the he'll ever get the credit he
quite deserves just because there just
hasn't been enough support around him I
like that and it was on my list and it
would have been a consideration for me
in round 2 I feel like he was never
coached at least not early yes right the
way he could have been and now he's he's
kind of going through this process where
he's being coached differently maybe
more aggressively
maybe being coaxed to be more of a
leader than he's ever been before and
it's kind of a strange mid to late
career adjustment for him but I hope he
stays with the lines there were those
weird reports last week
that there were trade talks the Lions
aren't trading him I don't rule out
Matthew Stafford maybe wanting a change
of scenery at some point but I think
that the Lions know that he's their best
chance to have a Kentucky right in 2020
and they're right back yeah I was just
gonna saying they're on their last you
know last strike here as far as Patricia
and Bob Quinn so they're not gonna want
to roll the dice yeah they need them
right right but back in 2009 you're
right he should have said Owen 16-team
no thank you I am out all right I'm
gonna go way back I'm gonna go back to
1987 one year after Bo Jackson pulled a
power play on the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
and took baseball instead Vinny
Testaverde who we have with this Super
Bowl week he should have said to the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers no thank you I'm
not doing it when you look at his career
it's a shame he played 21 years but I
feel like those first six seasons in
Tampa like if he'd have been somewhere
with a better coaching staff a better
organization he may have become the guy
he was kind of starting to be once he
ended up with the Browns once he ended
up with the Ravens right you know he had
thirty five interceptions in his second
year with the Buccaneers hey Jameis
Winston's got more work to do if he
wants to set the single-season an
interception record with the Buccaneers
he's five short because yes Vinny had 13
touchdown passes and 35 interceptions in
1988 it was a horrible team it was a
dreadful organization it would stay that
way until Tony Dungy became the head
coach and I you know it would have been
in hindsight better for Vinny Testaverde
to start his NFL career anywhere but
Tampa Bay yeah pretty much I mean Tampa
has probably got a few picks you know
and that what was that that second years
is that when we realized that or
everybody realized that Vinny Testaverde
was colorblind right is that how that
went down they didn't even realize it
until the second year of the NFL that's
crazy I also had Lee Roy Selmon on my
list too as a Tampa Bay guy to go hey
maybe he should have done that what are
we gonna say go ahead no I remember they
realized he was colorblind because they
stopped wearing their orange creamsicle
home jerseys they started wearing white
because he couldn't tell the difference
between the orange creamsicle Jersey and
the white jersey that the opposing team
was wearing so they had to start wearing
white at home Yeah right right that
I do I kind of remember that but this is
crazy the guy that won the Heisman and
did all those things had no idea he was
color blind until the second year in the
NFL
all right I you know I hate to do this I
don't know where to go here well I know
cuz I'm like I'm stuck in a spot here
I'm gonna go with one a little off the
radar a little just because Mike
Williams you remember Mike Williams the
receiver from USC right he's a top ten
pick you know in the previous two drafts
the Detroit Lions had taken receivers
Charles Rodgers and then Roy Williams so
I'm going with him because I go damn it
didn't work out with the first two guys
you were a big name coming out in the
draft from USC you should have just said
no sorry Detroit damn Detroit's on my
list twice I feel bad but they he should
have said oh okay up Matt Mullen he Matt
Millen he struck out with those two
receivers to hell with it I don't want
to go there that looks like a graveyard
for receivers so this maybe is not the
sexiest name ever but this is one that I
think kind of jumps out to me as far as
like there was a lot of clues and
context clues to not want to go to that
team at that point and wasn't Mike
Williams one of the guys who when
Maurice Clarett initially won his
lawsuit against the league keeping guys
out of the draft who were fewer than
three years removed from high school
didn't he like hire an agent become
ineligible and lose a year of college
football and and still was the 10th
overall pick I don't know I don't know
if I can say I remember that totally I'm
not sure about that so I can't I can't
go back and research that yeah alright
next one for me comes from 1999 do you
remember the 1999 draft Chris Sims yeah
I mean no not really I can't say
specifically go ahead that was the year
where there was a run on quarterbacks Oh
couch number one right Donna McNabb was
number two and taken third in the draft
that year was a kilee Smith right I
think a Kelly Smith should have said to
the Bengals go pound sand or pound salt
or whatever and I say that because from
time to time over the years I've
wondered if you just flip McNabb and
Smith if if the Eagles had taken a Kelly
Smith and paired him with Andy Reid and
if Andy Reid had groomed
chili Smith and tot Achille Smith and
worked with the killer Smith the way
we've seen Andy Reid take average
quarterbacks and turn them into great
quarterbacks what Achille smith have
become a fixture in philadelphia and if
donovan mcnabb had ended up being
drafted by the bengals would he have
washed out of the league I just I feel
like Achille Smith never really got a
chance to flourish in the NFL because he
got stuck with a crap team all due
respect right out of the gates and in
hindsight you know look we're talking
mainly about number one overall picks
although you went number 10 I think a
Kelly Smith not you know it should have
said hey no sorry I'm not interested
yeah in playing for the Cincinnati
Bengals well I mean it's it is it's a
real question I think we can probably go
back through time and look at a lot of
guys where we put them on a pedestal to
go oh they're great and then this guy is
just a and you know we think there's a
great difference in the player and you
know I think you know like what you're
saying here you could sit back and go
and argue and go I don't know if there's
that great difference as a player I
think the support system was just that
much greater on the guy we're putting on
the pedestal you know I think that is a
very real conversation that's gone on
throughout the history of time with the
NFL and Akili Smith man he did have
talent he did he came down you know hey
this just in Jon Gruden is a quarterback
horror dur okay and we had a Keely Smith
in training camp along with the rest of
the NFL's quarterbacks at the time at
some point but Akili Smith he had talent
I mean I remember watching him the first
time he let go with the ball I was like
damn that's pretty look at that thing
spin it was beautiful but yeah he was
scarred at that point already by
everything that had happened in the
Cincinnati is so dysfunctional he had no
confidence that way and he was really
trying to find his way and almost lost
in the NFL because of that bad to start
three other names I had on the list that
intrigued me mike vick because we had
some conference yeah and this year about
how the falcons never really developed
an offense around him right way the
ravens have with lamar jackson maybe he
would have been better off in a
different team in a different city to
start his career yeah I put Steve Walsh
on my list
remember the Cowboys made him the
first-round pick in the Supplemental
Draft right and they had just taken Troy
Aikman number one overall what the hell
are you doing Dallas Cowboys Jimmie
Johnson I think was still mad that
you know Troy Aikman spurned him and
went to Oklahoma instead of Oklahoma
State and then UCLA instead of his Miami
I think Jimmy was mad at him and finally
I put on the list just for fun the final
pick in round three of the 2003 would
have been if you weren't stuck with Jon
Gruden in Tampa Bay and that searing Sun
and everything that went along with it
you ever think about that like him
another team had drafted me how
different my career would have been I
mean apart from the fact that you would
have been playing the Carolina Panthers
on that hot Headz remember of 2006 just
generally do you think your career would
have gone differently if you had been
with a different team you know I mean
okay you know maybe I you know honestly
Mike I'll say this I don't think about
that as much as I think about whom
should I have really gone to Texas as a
young kid and gone to that school
that's the one where I probably second
guess more than anything right
the Tampa one because of the draft and
yeah you know I don't know I guess what
I'm saying is you got no control over
that you got no control right I was I
was accepting of that but also I think
me being with Jon Gruden in a lot of
ways was a blessing in disguise to I
learned a whole lot of football from a
guy at the time who was the cutting edge
man as far as offensive football was
concerned and it helped me throughout my
career it helps me right now to this day
as far as knowing football breaking film
down whatever it may be I wouldn't be
where I am if it weren't for Jon Gruden
and the things he taught me so I'm very
grateful for that
quarterbacks drafted before Chris Sims
in 2003 Carson Palmer Byron Leftwich Rex
Grossman cowboy Leone I can't I mean de
Vougeot got picked me for me because I
got to the point where it was like wow
this guy was kind of like you know a top
30 top 40 talent and now we don't want
to take him on our team in the second
round and like make the quarterback make
a quarterback competition with a guy
that's the son of Phil Simms but the one
that pisses me off is Kyle Boller that
one though I would still want to yell at
the Baltimore Ravens gonna what threw
more interceptions and touchdowns in his
college career and they dimmed they took
him because he threw the ball before the
goalposts through the goalposts from his
knee right and I damn I just wish I
would have done that
may be able to jump me up a whole bunch
of spots oh that's still something that
comes in very handy were you not aware
of that play in the playbook post from
your knees it works with some guys and
it buys them time and stock look at you
note Alex Tanny righties trickshot Tanny
it's it's bottom four more years in the
NFL because of it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports